And even know Noam Chomsky said
something about Sam Harrison,
Jordan Peterson, that,
uh, free speech does not,
it does not apply to hate speech.
Like why?
It's like, yes it does. Yes, it does.
That's crazy that someone who's really
smart can say it doesn't. Yeah. Okay.
So it's available on Youtube.
Um,
he say he puts some posts saying
that he was blocked from something.
It doesn't matter.
The point is,
one thing that's been shown is that
they're trying to silence more.
They're trying to stop the spread of
conservative ideology and spread liberal
ideology.
Like they're actively trying to do that.
I feel like there's a real worry
that when you have a platform,
whether it's youtube or something like
that, that you could get infected,
but like say shit posters if
ship posters just, they're more,
they're more prolific right there.
Like if you look,
just look at the comments on Youtube,
like in a lot of like really popular
things that comments are horrific,
like way disproportionate to how
they would be in the real world.
Like the comments and the p, the anger
that you find in a lot of youtube videos,
especially if you look at like the
comments of podcasts. Holy Shit Dude.
People are opinionated, right? They
got some crazy wild fucking opinion.
Now if you were youtube,
you'd be like,
we have to figure out a way to stop
people from saying Faggot or we have to
figure out a way to stop people from
doing this or stop people from uh,
from being homophobic.
We have to figure out a way to
stop people from supporting Trump.
We have to figure out a way to stop
people from talking about the wall.
You have to figure out a way and as soon
as you start doing that kind of stuff,
you run into a real slippery when
you're deciding what people shouldn't,
shouldn't be able to say,
even if it's legal.
That gets real weird because then you
don't have a free speech platform.
You have a left wing platform like your,
your platform has now left wing.
And I'm not saying you're wrong,
but I'm saying it,
it strengthens the position of the people
that you oppose because they are being
suppressed. Like you could see there
being suppressed. Even if they're wrong,
you put a guy in jail because his dog
says [inaudible] pop when he says see high
like boy you,
you just looked real fucking stupid to
most people and now the fight is on and
now it's going to be this swarm of
controversy where people are freaking,
I just found out about it yesterday.
I just found out about it last
night I think might not even,
it might've been this morning when
I woke up. Youtube is reported.
Oh, did you hear about your kids? Because
what this famous conspiracy theorists,
uh, his videos have been coming
up in the youtube kids app, uh,
teaching like flat earth type Shit and
like we didn't go to the planet where
moon good stuff. Yeah. What a good
motive is getting into a lot of,
you know, where they can,
whoa, there's too much.
Here's the thing about youtube
now is in defense of them,
because I'd talked though I had dinner
with some big wigs at Youtube and there
was some of the stuff they said was very
annoying and not calling things hate
speech that just weren't like,
I'm talking about someone
who got a community guideline
stripe because they put
a cup,
put a conversation up in their
playlist between Sam Harris and um,
Douglas Murray to intellectuals and they,
they said that it was because it
was hate speech and I was like,
that is the fact that they could just say,
that just drove me nuts.
But they're dealing with who knows
how many videos every day. I mean,
it's insane. How could they, how could
they possibly even know the videos? Okay.
The total number of people use Youtube is,
what is that number?
Oh my God.
301 billion.
300 million,
300 hours of video uploaded to youtube.
Every minute,
almost 5 billion videos are watched on
youtube every single day in an average
month, eight out of 10, 18 to
49 year olds. Watch youtube.
One of the things this woman said to
me that I, I agree with her on and on.
I mean, I believer because this
is not about about opinion,
is about how the way youtube works.
She said,
right now we have very crude tools to
find offensive speech, hate speech.
They're very crude tools and sometimes
the Mr Mark and sometimes when you're
dealing with like subtlety, like
humor, like I could say, hey you fuck.
And you know, people go, oh, he was angry.
Like obviously not, you hear the tone,
you know,
like someone saying that they're saying
it to friends and they're joking around,
they're being silly and everybody's
laughing. Youtube misses that. They don't,
they don't know what's
humor and what's not.
So are you saying that you can
never make a joke about, you know,
a guy's Dick or you can never make a joke
about a girl's vagina or you never beg
of joke about heterosexual sex, can
you? No. No, you can do that. Okay.
Can I make a joke about gay sex?
No. No, you can't. Oh, I see.
Because I'm not gay. Okay. Can I
make a joke about why people, yes.
Can you make a joke about black people?
No. Oh, okay. What do we do in here?
What are we doing? You're deciding
what people can and can't say.
And then they're also demonetizing things.
And we've had some demonetize
ones that were just like, okay,
there's gotta be some sort of an algorithm
going on here where there's a word we
say and that word triggers some sort of
a response and then they say that it's
up for, we, we, we have it up
for manual review sometimes.
The are Douglas Murray one where we
talked about youtube demonetizing videos.
That one got demonetized
says, so it's like, okay,
are they doing that to fuck with us or
are they doing that because he Douglas
talked about, um, radical
fundamentalist Islam.
Like what is it in their defense,
it's just their platform.
They should be able to do whatever
they want. Should they though,
because what are they then? If
it's, who is they? Who is they?
The people they hired [inaudible]
doesn't that shift? Like the,
the assumption is that everybody
who works in management,
everybody who works behind the scenes
all shares a mindset. That's crazy.
That doesn't even make any sense.
That's not even the society like group
think tanks like that. Like if, if,
if they all agree,
and this was one of the things that
James Damore pointed out about Google,
it's like they don't leave any
room whatsoever for conservatives.
Like they absolutely discriminated against
conservatives. I'm not conservative,
but if I was and I worked at
a company like Google, yeah.
Imagine how fucking on the
outside you would feel like,
is it illegal to be conservative?
Like isn't there a responsible ethical
form of conservatism that's not racist?
Not Homophobic,
but,
but presumes that a conservative
person in power would be more fiscally
responsible,
will have economic policies that they
agree with interventional his policies
they agree with.
I don't,
I don't think that that's outside the
realm of possibility that a reasonable
person could be conservative.
But if you work for any big tech
company that's not in the menu,
you don't get to be that.
Like you don't get to promote that.
You don't get to agree with that. It's
weird. It's not good because it's not,
it's not open speech. You're supposed
to be able to talk shit through. I'm a,
I like to listen to someone who has a
very strong opinion about something and
see if it resonates with me. Now, if
you stop the stop, that'll stifle that.
I was just going to demonetizing a
video though, isn't a censoring someone.
It's encouraging censorship.
This is why,
because you don't want to be demonetized
if you have a video and that video can
make you $500. If it's, um,
if it's up and it gets ads or it
can make you $0 million, but that's,
that's a $500 incentive for you to not
talk about whatever the fuck got it.
Demonetized right, but that's in the
debt then makes your argument, I'm like,
what were you making the
content for in the first place?
Or you just know it doesn't to me. No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. It's,
it's a motivation for you
to censor your speech,
whatever you're making it for in
the first place. You pursued that.
Someone was just making it to make it,
but there's an absolute monetary
value if they put ads on it.
So if they take away the monetary value
and they do it specifically because you
chose a certain subject that is in
fact a form of censorship there,
what they're doing is encouraging you to
self censor in order to make more money.
They could say, hey, you can do
whatever the fuck you want. Well,
we're going to decide that if
you talk about fill in the blank,
that subject no money,
so don't talk about that subject anymore.
They're not going to give
you money because they're
sharing that money with you
though that you could still share
that video on your Twitter channel.
You could still share it on your blog
and still make money if you can find her
on advertisers. It's just they see what
you're doing. I see what you're doing,
but it's not a good argument.
The reason why it's not a good argument.
It's because they made
a concerted decision.
They made a very clear decision to take
away the ads on videos where they don't
like what you're saying.
That just could be because they don't
have advertisers that are willing to pay
them. That's all. That's the way
I would look at it. The advertise,
the w didn't want to pay them because of
like Douglas Murray and Sam Harris Talk.
They just couldn't, maybe they couldn't
find the money for it and we're like, Hey,
guess what? This week, this is not
monetize because you don't know.
There's this weird to me,
I'm making a guess because you're doing
this to try to reinforce your original
opinion. I don't. I don't think it is
censorship. It's a form of censorship.
I think that the monetizing is not
a good thing because of other ways,
other reasons that it happens.
I'm on youtube because they didn't have
an incentive to share monetize videos
because they're making money on them.
I get that,
but it's just because it's the understand
that youtube who has a youtube has an
incentive to share monetize videos
because they're sharing in the profit of
every single video monetize video doesn't
a creators it get 100% of the money.
They get half of the money. Right?
Youtube gets the other half. So if a,
if a video is monetized there, they've
been a fitness sharing them. Right, right,
right. So that even reinforces more
the idea that they're censoring. Yeah,
that's what I'm saying. But
like the third, they're not,
they're censoring the
ability for it to share it,
to be shared in the youtube platform, not
on the Internet. That's true as a whole,
but they're not censoring.
What they're doing is promoting self
censorship by giving you a fiscal reward
for following their line. Again, that's
just where I'm saying like as a creator,
if you're making content to
just make money on youtube,
then you have to play by
their rules. Yeah, I do. I
understand what you're saying,
but what my point about all this is,
is what they're doing is they're there,
they're making their own.
They're making these decisions and who
is making these decisions that that also
could be definitely set. They should
say these are the rules, right?
I'm the person responsible for making
that statement. What are the rules?
Here's what they don't say. They don't
say, this is what's weird about it.
It's totally arbitrary. There's no like
written law that you have to follow.
There's no like,
oh you can't say cut.
Cause if you say con Playtex doesn't
want to advertise in your fucking video
anymore, right? No, there's
not that. It's weird. Yeah.
They don't tell you what to do.
Monetize video is like, when we get one,
they don't say it's because you
guys talked about about youtube. No,
they don't say shit.
It's fucking weird, man.
It was never fuck with me in eight years.
Youtube fucks with me every day. Right.
But the thing about Vimeo is the
difference in the numbers is so radical.
Like if we have a video that
gets a million hits on Youtube,
it will get 20,000 on Vimeo.